queen elizabeth ii has been at the
center of british life
for decades
since she became queen in 1952 she has
witnessed tremendous change within the
monarchy and across the uk oh really so
here are some of the biggest cultural
shifts that have happened during her
reign and the impact that she's had on
them
[Music]
queen elizabeth ii's coronation in 1953
was groundbreaking
previously only the upper classes were
deemed fit to watch such an event but
prince philip and queen elizabeth
realised that broadcasting the
coronation would break down class
barriers
the queen's decision to allow cameras in
for her coronation was hugely
controversial and the government were
vehemently against it but it went ahead
and actually revolutionized the way that
the monarchy
interacted with the media the little
prince saw his father pronounce the
words the event was watched by 27
million people in the uk and millions
more around the world
[Applause]
my whole life
whether it be long or short shall be
devoted to your service
and the service of our great imperial
family the queen's reign has coincided
with the evolution of a modern
commonwealth which her majesty herself
has said over the years bears no
resemblance to the empires of the past
when elizabeth ii began her reign
britain had a large overseas empire with
more than 70 colonies abroad but it was
an empire in decline and the years that
followed saw several countries gain
their independence from britain from the
independence of ghana in 1957 to the
handover of hong kong in 1997.
during this process of change the queen
provided continuity and an understanding
of britain's new role in the world
today the commonwealth is a voluntary
association of 54 countries who all work
together to promote shared interests
the queen has navigated evolving
relationships with new countries and has
been an ambassador for britain around
the world symbolizing unity and
friendship mr prime minister of canada
for making me feel so old
public royal engagements almost always
involve meet and greets with the public
now princess diana william and kate and
harry and megan have all charmed
well-wishers who came out to see them
it's hard to believe that those
walkabouts didn't happen until queen
elizabeth ii's reign before that
monarchies were famously inaccessible
and rarely came into contact with their
subjects
that all changed in 1970 when the queen
decided to personally greet royal
watchers on a trip to new zealand
[Applause]
and the tradition of walkabouts has
continued ever since
[Music]
tradition is really important to the
queen but she has been willing to move
with the times to make sure that the
monarchy remains relevant and in recent
years that's happened through younger
members of the family and things like
their social media channels
in the past divorce was taboo and queen
elizabeth's uncle edward viii was forced
to abdicate the throne due to his
relationship with divorcee wallis
simpson
at the time england's prime minister
argued that a divorced woman with two
living ex-husbands was politically and
socially unacceptable but attitudes
towards divorce have changed and the
queen's children have been allowed to
remarry
in some ways harry and megan's wedding
probably best symbolize this new vision
for the monarchy as they broke with a
number of different traditions
megan walked herself down the aisle the
couple had a gospel choir and it was the
first time an american bishop had spoken
at a royal wedding
harry and megan would go on to step down
from royal duties and accuse the royal
family of making racist comments about
their son archie forcing prince william
to go on the defense
is the the royal family a racist family
sir
we're very much not a racist fan
although harry and megan didn't directly
criticize the queen in their tell-all
interview with oprah winfrey their
comments threatened that image of a
modern monarchy
as society and the media have become
less deferential towards the monarchy
they have in some ways had to become
more accountable to the public who can
forget in 1997 when they were so heavily
criticized for how they handled the
death of princess diana despite a
national outpouring of grief the royals
did not fly a union flag at half-mast
over buckingham palace and there was at
first no public message from the queen
the queen and her grandsons were on
holiday in balmoral when the news of
diana's death broke and critics believed
the queen should have immediately
returned to london
eventually the queen did bow to public
pressure and came back to buckingham
palace to view the tributes left to her
former daughter-in-law she also gave a
broadcast the night before diana's
funeral which seemed to be a frank
admission of how the family had
misjudged the public mood we have all
been trying in our different ways to
cope
it is not easy to express a sense of
loss since queen elizabeth ii came to
the throne the world and britain has
dramatically changed her ability to read
the public mood and for the monarchy to
adapt has gained her great respect in
years to come it'll be up to younger
members of the family to keep on with
that sense of modernisation
well i think they're all lovely
[Applause]
oh